why don't you outline screenplays well i
think i described before what i like to
do i like to just do all the beats i
like to write the first act
have the you know the second act turn
and the the ending because i found that
like if you are too kind of sometimes
too methodical
about figuring it all out up front
uh you can't discover certain things
you know you'll find things that are
happening along the way that are like
surprises even to you and sometimes that
stuff becomes even better
you know you're like oh i didn't think
about that but you know how do i get
these guys from the end of act one to
the second second act turn
and you just discover it i know some
people that like to to do a complete
beat sheet you have to do that when
you're hired to write things you know
you have to give them a you can't do
that that's but for a spec purpose or
writing a script
you can you know have your own process
so it feels a little stale sometimes
when you have everything beated out you
know and you're like okay because that
two weeks you're writing out the beat
sheet
you might
get a better sense of your story and
your characters four weeks into writing
the script
and find things along the way that like
oh i never thought about that guy like
that or this like this do you get bored
when things are too easy
yeah
yeah good challenge yeah
because i get the sense you figure
things out very easily and so you want
to go to the next level
yeah especially well i think too you
have to kind of
as a screenwriter like reinvent like
where you want to go every couple years
too unless you're you're happy in the
area the area that you're in
so yeah no i guess i do yeah i never
thought of it like that but yeah i think
i'm always trying to like
reinvent or kind of come to get the next
level or do certain things and figure
out how it works so yeah i do
i like to make things hard on myself no
but that you just enjoy a challenge you
know you like to be you don't it's kind
of like i hate to use like a lab rat i
mean i'm sorry
but you know they they get the cheese
they get out okay they they solve the
thing yeah if you want to really boil it
down to that but we all kind of want
something more because if things are too
easy then it's just
everything's boring and then you can
become depressed yeah and i don't know
where i get it from but i'm really in in
to like getting things finished like
like i think i said earlier i'm never
happy till something's done i enjoy the
process more but i've been on movie
shoots and and things where it's getting
made i'm miserable the whole time
because i'm i still think something's
gonna go wrong you know when it's
finished and then i also have a weird
amnesia when projects are finished i
don't think about them again
i just move on i
think of
most of the films i've worked on that
have been made i've maybe watched once i
don't ever go back and watch them or
think about them and john carpenter has
that attribute if you watch the brian de
palma documentary he has that not that
i'm comparing myself to them but it's
like a good thing to have if you're
going to do this professionally it's
like once you're done with something you
just move on you don't even think about
that old project again it's like what's
next
how is someone who doesn't outline so
great at structure
that's a good question i think
i just know how
films work and watch a lot of films and
just just know that the structure will
find itself because i can i'm very open
to like okay
and i think i always have a good
understanding of like tracking tracking
characters is a very important thing in
script you have to make sure that
somebody hasn't disappeared too far out
of the story like if you have a bad guy
in something and he shows up page 20 and
then shows up page 40.
he can't disappear until page 90.
we have to see what he's doing at some
point so i i think i always have a
really good understanding of like making
sure we track people and like okay we've
seen this character do this now we have
to go back to that person we have to go
find that person
catch them all up put put them where
they go
so you know
and how do you remember do you have
almost have like um bullet points like
okay there's there's joe over here
there's there's mary and then making
sure that i'm i'm still seeing their
names somewhere within the last few
pages
yeah it's it's i don't know it's kind of
easy for me it seems easy i know some
people will like chart out where
characters are and so everybody has
their own process
you know and you can do note cards and
things like that i kind of always have
an idea where they're coming going and
you know and also too that's also part
of you get better right into you you
throw away any characters that don't
mean anything to the story you know if
you're a newer writer and you have all
these characters that don't mean
anything you're going to have a hard
time tracking people but if you you
really pay attention to films
especially commercial ones they don't
have a lot of
characters there might be a lot of
people in it but it centers around a
small group of people you know the
godfather might be one thing but i mean
if you look at indiana jones you know
it's always just him and then they'll go
to the bad guys and then they kind of
like you're along the journey with him
so it's yeah it's more like about
tracking those people but most studio
films don't have a lot of people marvel
films aside you know when the avengers
have like 8 000 characters but even then
if you watch the avenger movies they're
great at tracking all those different
people
you know they keep coming going out of
story just enough so you don't forget
them what about something like crash
crash that's a little bit different but
um
that's you know
yeah that's that's more the extreme but
i mean but i mean that's a kind of
different film you know the still is
anchored though by you know it's
anchored more by stories
you know
so yeah that's a good example but that's
a little bit different that's you know
and i don't know how many
kind of movies like that they're doing
nowadays because that was kind of hit
for a while you know the non-linear
bouncing around all these multiple
stories
so that yeah that's a different kind of
movie
right but it works you know yeah it was
excellent
can you provide a few questions that a
screenwriter or producer should ask
themselves before writing a movie or or
getting involved with a movie yeah i
think the biggest question is how do i
get it made you know if it's if it's you
know some kind of gigantic sci-fi epic
that cost 400 million dollars
you know it's it's like a non-starter
but i think you just need to really ask
you have to be passionate about it too
and really you know want to see it to
the finish line because it takes a lot
of work
i mean you want to get paid
but you know money is your main drive
that's not always you know
what happens there's things i've worked
on and worked on them so long that even
though i got paid well i probably end up
making you know a dollar an hour dollar
fifty you know if you timed it out but
it was like i was like i'm determined to
get this film finished so
i think that's the biggest question
because why write something if you're
not going to try to really get it made
or use it to get other jobs or create a
career you know if it's just for your
friends to read that's a whole other
thing all together
how many films do you think have been
made where
they were too ambitious in terms of the
budget and and a lot people just
couldn't be told no that happens all the
time and i mean it just happens in the
sense that like
you start and you something goes wrong
because with indie films the budgets are
so
precise that if something goes wrong it
could screw the whole movie up you don't
get to shoot that you now it's not 25
days it's 20 days you know there's so
many things that can go wrong but i
think that's where that has very little
do with the screenplay but more to do
with the director being able to like
change things and adjust things on the
fly and go okay that we can cut that out
we can move that to there and we can
save this whole thing and not make have
it be a mess but it happens a lot
so if you are hired for a screenplay and
you do have to do a beat sheet and you
submit it and then a couple weeks later
you come up with better ideas
are you stuck with that that same beat
sheet and that same progression no you
can i mean what you can do is is if
you're hired to write something you have
to communicate you know with the
producers because every step is tiered
it's like you get paid to start you get
paid when you turn in the beat sheet or
the treatment you get paid to start
writing the script but if you start
coming up with changes or figure things
out you can just you know get the
producers on the phone who who have paid
you to write it and throw your ideas at
them and they may love them they might
they might just say stick with the
beachy they might say oh that's great
let's try that so it's a process you
know you you have to be in really good
communication when you're taking money
from people and working with somebody
and keep them informed but you can't
make wholesale changes and go here it is
because
your agent will be calling you go why
are they calling me all pissed off and
you did this wrong you know so you have
to kind of like
you have to do what they want they're
hiring you to do something it's like if
they hired you to paint the house you
know gray you can't paint it red you
know and say oh i thought this section
would look better like this so
you're their employee but you know you
get the job by coming in with your own
take
and your own pitch which they like but
then it becomes theirs when they start
paying you and then you just have to
work with them you know but yeah most
great producers you come up with a great
idea you just run it by them they're
like oh that's much better so they're
not resistant to it but you have to
you can't just decide to go in the third
act a totally different way
would you say a lot of screenwriters
fail because they're not writing movies
that hollywood wants to make yeah i mean
you have to like it goes back to what
it's talking about with like you know
the business side of it you have to make
money for people you know it's it's not
it's not a
situation where people just trying to
throw money away or light it on fire so
if you cannot create a screenplay that
like producers think they can at least
get their money back and some because
sales agents take a cut everybody takes
a cut so you have to actually make some
profit on top of it
someone along the line is going to lose
money
and that's not what most people want to
do you know there's like i said there's
some
billionaires that just want to throw
money at things and and don't care but
those are few and far between so i think
yeah you have to be very honest with
yourself about what people are buying
you know you can't make some weird
you know film that like
speaks to you and your small group of
friends and expect somebody to give you
a million dollars to make it and no one
else gets it
and the universal appeal that you talked
about previously just sci-fi horror in
action
well that has foreign appeals so yeah
that that's part of the process too is
like you have to keep in mind that like
the form the the foreign mark there's
two markets the domestic market which is
you know north america and then the
foreign market which is the rest of the
world
that you know what a you know some movie
about
skateboarders in hollywood you know
in love might not translate in in you
know japan the same way a horror movie
would or a thriller so you it that
that's a whole nother section of money
that comes in on a film
so yeah it becomes harder and harder the
more esoteric something is now that's
where sometimes the greatest movies come
from you know like gasps brno makes
insane crazy you know esoteric movies
that that do really well and are cool
but
again those are few and far between and
in america i think
they're less likely to take chances and
europe i've worked with a few european
producers and they seem a little bit
more you know into the art they also
treat directors and writers a little
differently with a little bit more
respect and and or more the auteur
theory than than here but
you know it's it's part of the problem
is if you don't do stuff that people can
make money off of it doesn't be
commercial but it has to have a market
you